cette image là est très désagréable des
coûts dit à quelqu'un j'habite au mirail
de suite on vous plaît tout n'est pas
rose non plus c'est vrai est d'autant
plus que depuis quelque temps on a
l'impression que certains délinquants se
développe
peut-être avec l'arrivée de la drogue
dans le quartier ces propos illustrent
bien l'anc est réalisée par l'insee sur
ce coup mirail qui rassemble 50 de 10
personnes on y parle d'insécurité
d'impunité le chômage suisse 20%
vous allez rencontrer également une
grande diversité sur la situation
sociale du samu qui peut changer d'un
bâtiment à l'autre on a à la fois de
personnes vivant avec un très faible
revenu
mais à côté de cela des personnes qui
sont propriétaires de leur logement et
qui vivent avec plus de 15000 à 20000
francs par mois un mélange sur quatre
possède son appartement
les personnes les plus attachées à leur
quartier sont les retraités on a des
appartements ils sont très nerveux
lorsque vous avez deux enfants ces
enfants peuvent sans avoir besoin de
traverser une route dangereuse aller à
l'école
allez
dans un centre socioculturel il y a des
stades pacifier la situation du secteur
concerne les femmes et lebron chez les
mères élevant seules leurs enfants
et dans ce grand mirail de 20 ans en
décembre mais sont de nationalité
helvétique accro au début parce
qu'évidemment on n'a pas le même
religion n'a pas la même façon de vivre
nous tout ça et puis finalement c'est
vraiment été de l'amitié et puis on sent
qu'on est on est tous pareils la
sociabilité c'est partie des points
positifs évoquée par certains habitants
tout comme les transports jean michel
lui est sensible à la transformation de
la reynerie et beauty ouvrir un commerce
de jeu qu'on te ouvrir une librairie
papeterie presse sur la place abbal donc
je deviens intégration d un isolement
des autres selon manqué c'est s'il le
pouvait un habitant sur deux changerait
de quartier